well joining me now is Florida
Congressman Byron Donalds and Mike
Huckabee the former Governor of the
great state of Arkansas gentlemen thank
you so much for joining here tonight uh
Governor I want to start with you first
of all Merry Christmas uh Joe Biden
Unity I I I'm just not buying it after
two years of what we saw happen
yeah Merry Christmas to you too Jason
and to the congressman it was just
amazing to watch him say that this is
the guy who went before Independence
Hall and essentially denigrated half the
country and said that all of us who
voted Republican who were Trump
supporters that we were a threat to
democracy that we were dangerous people
uh this is insane and then he goes and
tries to pretend that he's Mr Unity but
he's the guy that not only has been
after Republicans but he goes after many
government employees like the border
patrol agents when he uh talked about
how horrible they were when they were on
the horses turns out what they did was
perfectly fine but this is not a
unifying president and it's a real
tragedy but the greater tragedy Jason is
the media they let him get away with it
they never call him out ever
yeah
yeah though there there is no
accountability no Challenge and they
just let it keep Sailing by uh
Congressman I want to talk about the
Omnibus it just happened
um you know the Appropriations bills are
supposed to be done by September uh
Democrats have the House and Senate and
the presidency but I want you to listen
to Senator Coons uh Senator Coons didn't
even really know what was in the bill he
but he voted for it
if you ever look at it and say
we've overdone it
well Joe I voted for the Omnibus and I'm
proud to support it but I don't like the
process I don't know exactly what every
other member of the Senate has put in
the bill
Congressman I mean this is the problem
nobody could have possibly read as more
than four thousand Pages he has less
than 48 hours to look at it
listen I'm telling you right now nobody
read this bill this was something that
was shoved on our throats about four or
five people negotiated most of what was
in it staffers basically wrote The Thing
through the midnight hours then we're
told hey you got to hurry up and do this
or the government is going to shut down
and here's the problem with this you
know we've sent another 45 billion or so
to Ukraine no accountability whatsoever
we're spending 400 million to secure the
border for seven countries in the Middle
East but in the same bill there is a
Prohibition of any money that goes to
Homeland Security from being used to
actually enhance border security here in
the United States so we're saying
expressly no funding of border security
here at home but we're going to do it
for seven other countries abroad it was
a terrible deal and listen it's the
holiday season Christmas is here but
what makes this worse is that you had
Senate Republicans who cut a deal with
Joe Biden and with Nancy Pelosi when
they didn't have to that's the one thing
that is so outrageous about it
yeah they needed to get to 60 votes they
only could do it with Republicans they
could have waited two weeks till the
calvary was coming over the hill and
Republicans were controlling the house
but nope that's not what they did
all right I gotta move on because
there's another grievance here uh
Governor that I want to address with you
uh Kamala Harris is reportedly
complaining that the media doesn't
adequately cover quote the strength of
her leadership telling confidence last
year that the media would cover her
differently if she was a white man
what's your reaction to the vice
president's comments
well if she was a white man they would
have covered her differently but they
would have excoriated her for the word
salad speeches that she gives you know
the saddest thing about her speeches
where she takes a word and Cycles it
over and over uh within a 50 word phrase
It's just embarrassing that the truth is
somebody wrote that speech for her she
didn't just give it on the cuff and
taxpayers are on the hook to pay
somebody to write speeches that are
honestly worse than a third grade
student council speech it's just
incredible so she should be grateful
that the Press isn't paying that much
attention to her because if they were
she'd really be in trouble
no great point now Congressman you're
just finishing up your first term uh
you've seen it up close and personal
when I when I came out of Congress in
2009 Nancy Pelosi was the speaker guess
what same same plan waited till about
December 23rd to pass out this
monstrosity of a bill same plan not an
accident but what's your impression
after two years uh there in the Congress
Washington is completely broken the
members don't even legislate they're not
sitting around crafting out what
appropriation bills look like the
biggest misconception for the American
people to understand is that there are
bells that are embedded in the clocks
all through the Capitol and when the
bells ring that's when everybody knows
it's time to head to the floor and vote
and instead of actually legislating we
spend our times pushing buttons and it's
a complete joke Congress has to be
reformed the committee process has to
actually work again members need to have
actual debate and actually deal with
these legislative inappropriative
appropriation Topics in a timely manner
we shouldn't be waiting until the week
of Christmas to figure out how you're
going to fund the government we should
be frankly Doing Network starting next
month February and March so that when it
comes time for next September the bills
are basically written and we know where
we're going to go you can make some
adjustments uh later down the line but
it's not working for Americans and that
is why voters continue to be frustrated
whether they were Republicans Or
democrats they are frustrated that
Washington isn't getting the job done
and I can tell you after two years the
way this place works it is an atrocity
and it doesn't work
governor do you have anything to add on
to that I've only got a few seconds here
a few seconds is all it will take amen
let's put Byron in some form of serious
leadership what he just said every
American is saying
go for it so yes amen and amen
appreciate that one Merry Christmas to
you too
Merry Christmas
Amen to that now the good thing is Nancy
Pelosi gave her final speech and I got
to cut off this segment by letting you
hear what she had to say on her way out
the door
I urge strong bipartisan I vote yield
back the balance of the my time in which
everyone a happy healthy and safe New
Year happy holidays Merry Christmas
Happy schwanza Happy Hanukkah whatever
it is you celebrate
happy happy swans happy schwanza uh
whatever all right Congressman
McDonald's Governor Huckabee have a
wonderful merry Christmas and happy new
year thanks for joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else